[Music]
what do the numbers tell us
how many people are infected with
covid19
what is the death rate among those who
have fallen ill
[Music]
the answers to those questions have
influenced policy decisions
like whether to impose lockdowns enforce
mask wearing
or encourage people to work from home
but often the official figures fall
short of reflecting the reality on the
ground
and the stakes of getting it wrong could
hardly be higher
[Music]
welcome to arkovit 19 special i'm monica
jones and
like many of you i've been staring at
daily statistics for the last 18 months
how many new infections are there in my
neighborhood my hometown my country
and what's the situation like elsewhere
for example where i have friends and
family
but what do those numbers and curves
actually mean
and can they be trusted in
india the scale of suffering caused by
the coronavirus defies comprehension
official figures put the number of
deaths at 423
000 but experts believe that may be a
vast
undercount the real figure according to
a report by the center for global
development
could be 10 times that it's thought that
poor healthcare infrastructure in rural
areas
as well as lack of access to testing may
have led to the dramatic
under-reporting of coronavirus cases in
the country
one method researchers use to determine
whether covid19 deaths are being
accurately counted
is to compare the figures to the rate of
excess deaths
over a given period
take russia for example between the
beginning of april
and the end of june of this year the
country recorded well
over half a million more deaths than
usual
just over a quarter of them were
attributed to covet 19.
while there could be other reasons to
account for the excess
deaths it's one indicator that
coronavirus cases
may be going underreported despite that
moscow authorities have recently been
easing restrictions
with people no longer obliged to show
proof that they've been vaccinated
or have immunity in order to sit in
indoor venues
but not everyone trusts the official
data
the spread of the infection has
decreased there are fewer sick people
now
moscow mayor sergey sobian says
i think this data is partially faked
it's done so that we'll feel safe
why take it
they're looking at europe in particular
if their infection numbers go down
our should show that too
interpreting official figures isn't
straightforward
whether or not the data is catching
asymptomatic cases can have a big impact
on death rates for example
so can other factors like whether the
infection is mainly spreading among the
young
or old as well as accuracy
there's the more fundamental issue of
transparency
so far north korea has told the world
health organization
that it has not detected a single case
of covid19
in the country international observers
have cast doubt on that claim
with some reports suggesting that
quarantined north koreans are being
treated like pariahs
an extreme example perhaps of a wider
truth
the less data available the more
dangerous the virus
well for more i'm joined by andreas
backhouse he's a research fellow at the
federal institute for population
research so very good to have you with
us and i believe as early as february
you already suspected the low death
count in india is due to massive
under counting how did you come to this
conclusion
on what evidence did you base it
thank you for having me monica um
actually it was quite easy to come up
with this
theory i would call it by then because
we already had
zero prevalent surveys from india who
were estimating the number of truly
infected
among the indian population and even
before the large well
wave of delta happened in india
we already knew there had been maybe
up to 200 284 million cases in india
which meant the official case count was
under counting by a factor of 28.
and just from that that made very much
sense to
conclude probably the death the covet 19
death must also be heavily under counted
then
because if your testing capacities are
so constrained you will not have the
test to run them on the deceased people
right so the numbers just didn't match
uh but statistics about new infections
or the numbers of death
they are supposed to help decision
makers assess the situation and come up
with adequate measures
that of course is hard when the data
isn't reliable how can
this problem be solved
well let me look at the bright side
first of course the covet 19 pandemic is
already
the best documented pandemic in human
history by far
because day by day we can publicly trace
the evolution of the pandemic
basically in real time and every day we
are adding new knowledge about the
pandemic
that said the data cannot answer all of
our questions
either because it's not providing the
right information we need at this point
in time
or because our analysis aren't
conclusive
which really isn't a bad thing working
in research
data not being conclusive or being kind
of messy
that's just a totally normal workday of
researchers yeah but it requires a
certain
it requires a certain data literacy uh
from policy makers because to them it
it has to be conclusive else they can't
act
well i would say it requires data
literacy among the people who are
informing the policy makers
which are fortunately often skilled
researchers
and the main advantage that we have in
science as researchers
is that what we are doing is really
mostly about figuring out which data we
can trust
which analysis is conclusive and which
is not and we achieve this by
submitting our analysis to our peers who
will then subject
it to a very tough review and challenge
our interpretations that happens
all the time it's not always pleasant i
can tell you
you cannot always come up with a fully
convincing response
but that's how it the works always being
fully conclusive on every question
that's just the norm
right but of course there are different
approaches and different approaches also
in different countries
and even correct or similar approach of
data
can lead to confusion for example there
are i believe uh different concepts used
to measure mortality from cyrus kovi to
there is the case fatality rate the
infection fatality rate
and the mortality rate how should those
terms be used so they
make sense in a statistic
indeed these are the most mixed up terms
in the whole pandemic probably
so the case fatality rate that's
basically what we started out with in
march
2020 it's just you take the number of
covert 19 deaths and you divide it by
the number of kobit 19
cases right so the case fertility rate
is the easiest one to compute but it's
also the most biased one by the testing
regimes in different countries
at different points in time the
infection fatality rate
tries to give a real estimate of the
danger of dying from covet 19 by taking
all infections
into account those that have been
detected as cases and those that have
gone
undetected for which we do these large
zero prevalence
infection surveys like in the uk finally
the mortality rate
that's really more of a demographic term
that's just
the total number of people who've died
from a disease relative to the total
population that is really more
retrospective
perspective on the disease
all right well then andreas backhouse
from the federal institute for
population research
thank you so much for your time and for
sharing your insights with us
now the pandemic seems to have split
society into two groups
those who seek answers from experts and
those who reject data they don't
understand
and where does this leave science as a
whole time to ask derek
what impact has the pandemic had on the
public perception of science
one of the things the pandemic has done
is radically changed the way that many
of you out there in the public
view science and scientists
some have turned into really famous
figures who are now
really well known not just in their home
countries but but all over the world
germany also of course gained a few new
science celebrities in 2020
the most prominent of them virologist
in chief christian dawson millions of
germans tune in
for his regular pandemic podcasts
he's even been turned into a traditional
christmas ornament
so one way covett19 has certainly
changed public perception of science
is by dragging researchers and science
experts out of the shadows
they've mostly worked in up until now
and
thrusting them and their fields onto
center stage
i mean i'm sure there are lots of kids
here in germany now saying
i want to grow up to be the next
christian boston and and if you ask me
that's a great thing and i'd like to
make another point about
public perception and and science um
in a series i've been watching recently
a passionate
researcher at one point bursts out and
says science
improves lives and shines light on the
glorious world around us
um it's a beautiful way of saying
something that that i
i personally have always believed but
the astounding thing is how many
other people now seem to have been
convinced of it too
um back in pre-pandemic days i used to
regularly bore people at dinner parties
with my excited monologues about
new research now i regularly have
lively discussions on covid science with
everyone
from the kids in my street to my
mother-in-law
about everything from from aerosol
behavior to to the speed
of mutation and viruses um so
so this year i think has driven a lot of
people who used to be
bored with or or afraid of scientific
topics
to engage with them in in amazing
ways and and i'm hopeful that that
interest
will remain long after the pandemic
is brought under control
[Music]
thanks for watching
[Music]
you